what's the other question um there's
only one other real problem I had where
God says that he's jealous and vengeful
because the first I don't know I just
thought he's got nothing to be jealous
of he has why should he
be you know like I guess we're Made In
His Image too right there's no reason
asking why is being jealous about
characteristics I don't know when Jesus
describes describes his father it's it's
as a a merciful like I always thought if
if God was jealous and vengeful Satan
wouldn't be here so hold on you
selectively choose the parts of Jesus's
words you like and then you reject the
words you don't like you mean the same
Jesus who talks about having to destroy
Jerusalem and the temple because of
their rejection of him that same Jesus
no I do understand that there's
righteous there's a time for righteous
anger I do get that I just think the
word jealous is what I had a problem
with okay but my question is who told
you jealous y or being jealous is a bad
characteristic where'd you get there
from I don't know I guess from myself
it's it's not really based on anything
exactly so what you're telling me is you
are now determining what is right or
wrong due to your desires and whims but
you're not gone yeah that's true too and
and I can't possibly hope to understand
you me well not only that let's take a
step further I'm going to show you
jealousy
is not a bad
trait what happens is even the good
traits that God endows us with as a
reflection of his character can be
corrupted and be used for evil purposes
for example food eating food having
desire for food is not sinful right no
of course not but then what if you
become a gluttonous pig and a food
addict ah I say what you getting that
yes absolutely even the desire for sex
was created by God right so that we can
can come and join ourselves with a woman
right become abely yep what happens when
you take that natural desire and now you
pervert it and use it to fornicate
commit
adultery and let it control you yeah I
understand okay now to show you the same
Jesus who says God is love same Jesus
who say God is love the same Jesus who
tells John in Revelation and I can you
other passages even in the gospels then
the kings of the Earth and the great men
and the commanders and the rich and the
strong and every slave and free man hid
themselves in the caves and among the
rocks of the mountains and they said to
the mountains and to the Rocks fall on
us and hide us from the presence of him
who sits on the throne and from the
Wrath of the lamb for the great day of
their wrath has come and was able to
stand yeah okay okay now let's let's go
back with jealous why would God be
jealous for you and why is it bad okay
let's take it in its historical cultural
context god is perfect we are not but
God created us in a way to reflect his
characteristic right his character okay
now you give yourself wholeheartedly to
a woman okay you have been nothing but
faithful and kind and youve provided for
her you care for her you don't
disrespect her you love her and cherish
her but she's constantly leaving you for
other lovers and when these lovers use
her and abuse her and dump her she runs
back to your
arms yeah yeah that's yeah that's
understandable that's not a bad jealous
that's a hurt jealous because God Likens
Israel to his bride yes he does and he
says instead of loving me who has done
nothing but love them care for them
provide for them redeem them protect
them from their enemies they keep
running after other lovers the foreign
gods of the Nations because they desire
the members of those lover lovers
because I'm not delightful to their eyes
they keep running from me they keep
abandoning me get ravished by their
lovers and then I end up taking them
back over and over again and this is a
pattern with them and
me so is God completely just and
righteous for being for his bride and
upset that his bride is
constantly abandoning him for other gods
that they find more attractive and
better endowed even though those gods
have done nothing for them absolutely
same that's another probably another
reason that I was worried too because
the Jews had done that throughout their
time I was worried that they' done it
again you know but I do like the way you
explain I I I love the way you explain
the jealous things Sam I've never looked
at it like that brother well I'm going
to give you some examples from script
and by the way the story of the New
Testament by the way if you don't know
what it is is that God finally gives
Israel the divorce she wanted if you
haven't watched my series I've done
several series one it's the great
divorce the story of the New Testament
is God keeps pursuing Israel his bride
they keep wanting other lovers and they
keep cheating on him he keeps taking
them back until finally he says enough
is enough I can't make you love me I
can't make you desire me so want to hand
you what you want you want a divorce
here you go you're free and that's why
Jesus came now to establish his church
so God's covenant people is no longer
the nation of Israel it is the community
of
Believers that consists of both Jews and
Gentiles will be baptized in Christ now
let me give you an example why God is
just here look he Now commands HOSA a
prophet to do the following watch Hosea
chapter 1 watch when when Yahweh first
spoke through HOSA Yahweh said to HOSA
go take for yourself or hosiah hosia a
wife of Harlot tree let me see if I can
get a paraphrase sometimes people won't
get what the Harlot tree means right let
me do
NIV why would God him do that you have
any
idea uh I think I might it's probably
the same say he can understand how it
feels for him right yes exactly what it
says right here josea one you got it he
says when the Lord began to speak to
hosiah the Lord said to him go marry a
promiscuous woman and have children with
her for like an adulterous wife this
land Israel is guilty of unfaithfulness
to the
Lord so he married goer daughter of blim
and she conceived and bore him a son did
you catch it yes he said I want you to
know what it feels like for me
Israel the people
my wife are whing around prosting
themselves keep leaving me to go and act
as other lovers and I keep taking them
back you want to probably turn off your
phone you want me there it's my wife she
needs to be picked up from the dentist
team you can pick up real quick and say
I'm on a live stream so she doesn't
divorce you I don't want you to get inou
I'm on a la stream see can you guys
start the Sho and I'll
I don't want her to abandon him I'll
you okay good see you love you all right
okay now you see what God said I want
you
to feel what it feels like to be go to
be me Israel my wife doesn't desire me
doesn't want me keeps running after
other gods which liken to committing
adultery fornication and I keep taking
them back so my wife is a and I still
take her back now watch here
right I'm going to show you chapter
three you read the entire chapter later
but now Josiah's wife was named gmer she
left him to go back to being
a Josiah's wife HOSA hosia left him to
go be back to going back to be a now
look what he says
here hoseah chapter 3 look the Lord said
to me go show your love to your wife
again though she is loved by another man
and is an adulterous love her as the
lord loves the
Israelites though they turn to other
gods and love the sacred raisin
cakes see that yeah so you see what God
is saying yeah just like your wife is a
commits adultery my wife is a
ad three but I love her so much I can't
let her go I keep bringing her
back I've been in that situation I know
exact and it does it breaks your heart
I've been I've been in that situation
cost me my daughters anyway now if you
want to see the heart of God in the Old
Testament here you go go well the well
look oseah chapter 11 right I'm going to
read the first 11 verses you ready y
tell me if this doesn't sound like the
god revealed in Jesus okay look when
Israel was a child I loved
him I loved him and out of Egypt I
called my son now watch but the more
they were called the more they went away
from me you see my son the more I called
him to me the more he didn't want to
have nothing to do with me so it said
who did my son run after the the B the
false god B and his various mutations
they actually wanted Bal as the father
as husband not me and they burn incense
to images now watch the imagery God is
liken himself to a father and a mother
and a husband it was I who taught
Ephraim to walk taking them by the arms
but they did not realize it was I who
healed them now let me give you the
imagery here do you have children
brother I do yeah now imagine you have a
son you have done nothing but love your
son provide for your son care for your
son and you taught your son baby steps
but then there's time he says you know
what I don't want you as a father I want
that guy as my father and I'm gonna ask
him to adopt me what would it do to you
oh
brother I can't even imagine well that's
what they did to God that's what he's
saying
well so you understand when you
understand the god of the Old Testament
he's just as every bit loving and
beautiful and humble as the god
revealing Jesus cu the same
God see I feel really guilty now man I
feel really it's okay God's going to
heal you but now watch so you know look
what he says it was I who taught Ephraim
to walk taking them by the arms in other
words I taught my son baby steps but
then my son said I don't want you I want
Bal as a
father even though you fathered me now
watch I led them with cords of human
kindness with ties of Love does that
sound like a true God or the god
revealed in Jesus yeah sounds like the
god revealed in Jesus he said I did
nothing but love them and care for them
but to them I was like one who lifts a
little child to the cheek you know what
he's saying you know what the imagy here
is and me down to feed them this is the
imagery brother I want you to look he's
saying this is how I am to them he took
them as a little child your baby put
them to my
cheek that's the imagery and then he
says like a good parent I stoop down to
feed them here you go that's the imagery
that's how God is describing
himself you understand I do you see how
powerful that imagery is I do so now
watch what he says even though I did
that then he asks a rhetorical question
will they not return to Egypt and will
not Asser rule over them because these
were the Nations whose gods that the
Israelites kept turning to to worship
because they refuse to repent are they
going to keep going back to these
gods and now he says well if you don't
want me you don't want my protection and
if you don't want my protection guess
what happens kingdoms will come and
ravish you and slay you a sword will
Flash in their cities it will devour
their false prophets and put an end to
their plans now watch look at where
you're going to really when I read this
the first time I started balling why
because verse eight
my people are determined to turn from me
you see they are determined to turn away
because they don't want to have anything
to do with
me even though they call me God most
high I will B by no means exalt me
because they don't want me they pay lip
service to me they want other gods but
now look at his heart now you tell me if
this doesn't sound like
Jesus he's
angry because he has to punish them but
now he's heartbroken because he has to
discipline his son look look at his
words how can I give you up
Ephraim how can I hand you over
Israel how can I treat you like adma how
can I make you like Zabo meaning how can
I wipe you out completely I
can't what I did to Sodom Gomorrah I
can't do to you I cannot bear to see you
suffer but you leave me on choice
because look what he what he says my
heart is changed within me all my
compassion is aroused meaning you're
breaking my heart because you're leaving
me no choice to discipline you but
because I love you I cannot stand the
thought of having to wipe you out and I
won't I can't because I love you too
much
see that's why then he says I will not
carry out my Fierce anger as angry as
you've gotten me I will not like you out
I can't why because you're my
baby you're my baby and I can't do it I
will not care at my Fierce anger nor
will I devastate Ephraim again for I'm
God not a man meaning I'm a God who
keeps his word I'm a God who does not
lie I'm a God who's not double-minded
like men are the Holy One among you I
will not come against their cities they
will follow the lord he will roar like a
lion like when a lion roars for its prey
and they come not pray Roar lion roars
for its Cubs and it comes I will Roar
for my Cubs then they will recognize me
when he Roars his children come
trembling from the West they will come
from Egypt Ching like sparrows from
Assyria fluttering like doves I will set
on them hes declares the Lord see that
yeah now does that sound like God is a
cruel God merciless God n not at all
you're right Sam they've plucked bits
and pieces um from the Old Testament to
make him look bad
but it's the same thing that the Muslims
do with the New Testament exactly now
watch that's why I wanted I wanted so
much to speak to someone it's my
responsibility to know the Bible better
than I do well it's a shame it's a shame
I haven't read read the whole thing you
will you learn you learn but one thing I
want you to catch
again right here you see the heart of
God now watch here God it seems like
he's so broken like he's crying
right right the picture oh how can I
give you up my heart is right yeah you
know why because this is The God Who
then becomes the man Jesus now watch
this is the same Gody now watch
here Luke 1941-44 tell me if it sounds
the same as he approached Jerusalem they
saw the city he wept over
it and said if you even you had only
known on this day what would bring you
peace but now it is hidden from your
eyes the days will come upon you when
your enemies will build an embankment
against you and encircle you and hem you
in on every side they will Dash you to
the ground you and the children within
you your walls they will not leave one
stone on another because you did not
recognize the time of God's coming to
you see he's crying he's heartbroken you
know why yeah because you don't want me
therefore you can't have my protection
and if you don't have my prediction that
means Nations will come and ravish you
but what else could I do when you don't
want
me you don't want me so imagine husband
and wife or children they say we don't
want you here we don't want you in this
house get out of
here and as heartbroken as you are you
leave and then all of a sudden all these
men come into your house use and abuse
your wife and take advantage of your
children but you can't do nothing about
it because you were not want
it yeah this is how God is describing
himself they don't want me what do you
want me to do see I I looked at as that
as a floor of he that it's not he's
floor it has you got it and if I were
read Ezekiel 23 you'd start balling but
let me show you how beautiful this art
is not just for the Jews look Old
Testament right look look what he says
what about the Foreigner The Stranger
look what he say says to them look at
here watch how beautiful loving this God
of the Old Testament is when you read
things in context context let me go and
I Legacy can be sometimes hard let me
just do this I want you to watch
this all righty then now when you read
in context there's no problem now watch
here when a foreigner resides among you
in your land meaning a non-israelite but
wants to live in your land right yeah do
not mistreat them the Foreigner residing
among you must be treated as your
neighbor n native born love them as
yourself for you are foreigners in Egypt
I am the Lord your God does this sound
like a tribal God or does it sound like
the god of creation who loves all
nations equally yeah he loves everybody
and say to be traded fa yeah yeah look
at this Deuteronomy 10
17:19 for the Lord your God is God of
gods and Lord of lords the great God the
mighty and awesome who shows no
partiality and accepts no rights he
defend the cause of the fatherless and
the Widow and loves the Foreigner
residing among you oh so God loves the
non-israelites
but I thought he's a cruel God he's not
like Jesus he loves the Foreigner among
you giving them food and clothing I love
them they're all mine and you are to
love those who are Foreigners for you
yourselves were foreigners in
Egypt does it get any more beautiful
than this no it doesn't seem I'm gonna
have to go brother my wife gonna want to
leave okay last thing though keep in
mind you understand why he's jealous I
do my
brother what is his heart's broken yes
so that means jealousy is not a bad
characteristic it's a right if I love
you and I created you and I gave birth
to you spiritually and I clothe you and
this is how you treat me no he's perfect
but anyway absolutely Lord bless you
brother same God bless you too thank you
so much for giving me your time mate I
really do appreciate it bless God bless
go back to the Catholic Church take the
eukar I'm going back trust me confession
and the Eucharist God bless Sam God
bless